MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Good morning, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
My name is Matthew Hendershot.
I am the video editor,
post-production guy
for the Talks at Google team.
And for the past year, I've
also served as a very personally
satisfying role as director
for the original online series,
"Songs of the Road."
Joining me here today
to talk more about Song
Craft presents and
"Songs of the Road"
are the stars of the show,
Ben Arthur, singer/songwriter,
radio host Rob Reinhart, and
producers Al Houghton and Mike
Crehore.
Good morning, guys.
Good morning.
What don't we go down
the line, and you
guys can just personally
introduce yourself.
Tell us a little bit
about your background
and what your role
is with the show.
BEN ARTHUR: Sure.
My name's Ben.
I do the songwriting.
So we bring in an artist,
and I sit down with them,
and write and record a song in
a very brief period of time.
ROB REINHART: I'm Rob Reinhart.
I host a syndicated
radio program
called, "Acoustic Cafe."
We're in our 21st year.
And in this project,
I drove the car.
I played the bald guy.
Look at all this hair up here.
BEN ARTHUR: Not that he's
self-conscious, or anything.
ROB REINHART: And,
along the way,
have done some interviews with
the artists that are involved
in the Song Craft project.
ALAN HOUGHTON: I'm Al
Houghton, musician, producer.
I have a studio downtown
called Dubway Studios.
And we're involved in
producing the music
that the songwriters write.
MICHAEL CREHORE: And
I'm Mike Crehore.
I was partners with
Al at Dubway Studios.
That's how we met up
with Ben originally.
And helped to produce
the music, and capture it
in whatever strange place where
we needed to capture it in, so.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Now Rob, as you said,
you've been doing Acoustic
Cafe for over 20 years.
ROB REINHART: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: What
brought you into this situation,
where you were starting back
over the brand-building process
in a whole new medium--
that of online video--
and with a whole
new group of people?
ROB REINHART: Yeah.
You know, actually,
it's interesting.
I've been turning down video
options since the late '90s.
People who have
come along and said,
you really have stuff on video.
This is probably 1997, '98.
And the reason I wanted to
get involved with this project
was it specifically
was not going
to be the thing that
I wanted to avoid,
which was yet another series
of guys and girls with guitars,
in high definition,
playing their songs.
I just thought,
you know, the web
was sort of flooded with that.
And I didn't see any
reason to contribute to it.
I didn't see how it would
extend my brand any.
What I was interested
in doing was
something that had a
narrative, something
that presented a new story.
It wasn't just an
artist doing what
they do on my radio
program, but with pictures.
Instead, it actually
had a story to it.
And so that's what was such an
attractive thing when Ben sort
of threw this idea out there.
It was an interesting
way to tell a new story.
That's why.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So this was about 2013
when the conversation began for
us to start working together.
But we had been doing
this narrative approach
for quite a bit more than that.
Ben, why don't you talk
about how the three of you,
and then, ultimately, I got
involved in that, came about.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, so
for a couple years
we had been just
throwing artists together
in the guys' studio
and writing songs
with them-- John Wesley
Harding and Ximena Sarinana
and a whole bunch
of other folks.
And we needed to grow our
ability to distribute that
and to bring in great artists.
And Rob knows everyone.
All of the artists.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: From the
video standpoint, when we all
got together and
started doing this,
we wanted to tell it as
like a reality TV show.
But we knew we were not
going to be on TV at first,
so it was all about being
online, trying to find a way
to publish it online.
I think some of the first ones
we published in five parts.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And so
we could keep the size down,
and keep it contained as
something people would watch.
And then, we also did it in
Dubway Studios, your studio
downtown.
So we had a little bit of a
contained studio space as well,
right?
Why don't you guys
talk about the process
that we were going
through back then,
and how it all came
together as a show.
ALAN HOUGHTON: Well,
you know, initially it
was pretty small minded.
It was like, wow, how do
we get more, you know,
studio hours in the studio?
But then it became
obvious, this is actually
way more interesting
and cool than that.
So by putting songwriters who
don't know each other at all,
there's a drama
element, automatically.
And we did not know
how that would manifest
or what would happen at all.
In fact, we were thinking
almost more technically.
You know, people'll be
interested in like what
mike you use, and how you
use the software, and all
this stuff.
And as, as it evolved,
it became more apparent
that actually the dynamic
of the songwriting
is much more the cool story.
And the other stuff became
less and less critical
as we went on.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So
2013, South by Southwest,
we decide to go down
and take a crack at it.
How did that go?
ROB REINHART: Well,
you know, actually,
so you guys started in
'09 doing this at Dubway?
BEN ARTHUR: Somewhere in there.
ROB REINHART: Because it was
'09 that you first brought this
idea to me.
And I think I said, well, I
don't see any money in it.
And not to be totally mercenary
about it, but it really
was like, you know, to
really do this well,
I think it's going
to require a lot.
And for 2013, the key
to going down there
was being able to make sure
that we weren't just doing
this, paying for it
out of our own pockets,
and having a go at it.
We were not part
of the festival.
We were doing this
kind of rogue.
It was a rogue project.
We got a condominium
on Riverside.
We just set up, and we
invited people to come.
And we kind of cobbled together
from some independent sources.
You know, just people who would
advertise on the radio program
would underwrite the
videos, would get, you know,
placement within the videos
which sort of started us
down that path.
So being able to pay
for it-- and nobody lost
any money on that--
and we were able to pay
our artists a little bit
of money to participate,
it sort of changed the
dynamic a little bit,
and made it something
that we were all
working towards in a different
way than just doing it for fun.
BEN ARTHUR: And the
studios were awesome.
ROB REINHART: The
songs were fantastic.
Four of them.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Was it four?
Or was it three?
ROB REINHART: Four.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I want
to touch back on something.
We got a condominium.
You mentioned that.
And Al, you went
down the first year.
ALAN HOUGHTON: No, Mike.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Mike.
Mike, you went down the
first year to do that.
Talk about leaving, you know,
multimillion dollar Dubway
Studio's facility and
going down to record
these things in a condo.
MICHAEL CREHORE:
You kind of have
to think outside of
the box a little bit.
And, but you know,
the whole world
has, has come to this
gorilla recording thing
and embraced it.
I mean, just look at
YouTube and anything else.
Everybody is both
recording, and taking video,
and doing it themselves.
And Al and I both
came-- even though we
had a beautiful
studio to work in-- we
came from a
do-it-yourself background.
So early on, we were-- you know,
before they had computers--
were working with 2-tracks,
and 4-tracks, and 8-tracks,
and 16-tracks, whatever we
could afford to kind of get
the process going.
So for me, it was pretty
invigorating to go.
Ben said, hey, let's go to South
by Southwest and do this thing.
And I'm like, yeah, OK.
So we took a couple of small
interfaces down with us.
I think we had four inputs.
We were working in a
condominium, which meant Ben,
you have to get up now,
because the guys are going
to be here in a half hour.
And we've got to move your
bed out of the living room
and put it into the
bedroom so we can work.
And but it was nice.
And everybody,
everybody who came was,
were in it for the, for
getting the best song
they could get in the moment.
And when that happens,
it just makes the,
makes the process easy.
I mean, later on, we had to take
the things back to the studio
and enhance some of
the productions a bit,
which is also fun for me.
Because I get to play a lot of
instruments and put on a lot
different hats.
But it was great.
I mean, you just have
to capture that moment
when Ben and this artist
get the kernel of a song.
And I think Rob, that
first year he was saying,
you know, he's he's, sweating.
He's going, I don't know
if this is going to work.
Does this really work?
Is this really going to work?
ROB REINHART: Something I
continue to do to this day.
MICHAEL CREHORE:
And so go ahead.
Tell them--
ROB REINHART: Well, we should,
we should point out though,
and we should just make it very
clear that what we were doing
was trying to create a
brand new song-- brand
new song-- from nothing in about
a three hour period of time
with these artists.
We didn't have them for long.
We just had them
for a few hours.
We were working in a
space that really was not
much larger than this stage.
MICHAEL CREHORE: No,
it was probably--
ROB REINHART: You put
the kitchen there.
That's it.
This was the condo
we were working in.
And everybody brought
different ideas.
I mean, some brought
no ideas whatsoever.
I mean, they really
just-- Ben and the artist
staring at each
other for a second.
Now we go.
And we were capturing
it on video and audio,
and yeah, it was a little scary.
Sure.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, and
I think one of things for me
on the video direction
standpoint that
was important was always
telling the real story,
and then focusing on
that creative moment.
One of the things that we talk
about us as creative people
is like demo-itis.
Or that, you know,
when-- the first time
you draw a picture, the
first time you do something,
you're like, aw,
this is perfect.
And then, the more you work on
it, the more you work on it,
you get further and further
away from that initial charge.
And I know that's a big
philosophy of yours, too, Mike,
is like, catch it
in that first time.
So I think that we really
embraced that, going down
to say, this is the situation.
This is the reality
of it all, right?
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, and the songs
aren't meant to be necessarily,
like, you know, sometimes a
live song goes on an album,
and some of the falling
apart is beautiful.
But the mess, you know,
is really compelling.
And the fear and the
excitement of trying
to remember the lyrics and
trying to play it right
is present, and adds,
heightens the song.
So, you know, we've had
artists come on the show,
and write a song
with us, and then
re-record it for their record,
you know, get in the studio
and take their time.
But that, that
freshness is exciting.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So we have
a video clip our first year
down to South by Southwest,
and this features an artist
from upstate New York
named Sean Rowe, who
came in with a really, kind
of haunting melody and idea
for a song that came
together, and was sort of one
of our biggest successes.
BEN ARTHUR: That year, yeah.
MICHAEL CREHORE: And also,
he was the first one.
ROB REINHART: The
very first one.
MICHAEL CREHORE: He was
the first one at South
by, so when, as Rob and I were
going, is this going to work?
As soon as he opened
his mouth, and you'll
see you'll hear this, we
went, oh, yeah, he's great.
BEN ARTHUR: And the fun
thing about the song
is that he'd been
working on this chord
sequence and this
melodic idea that he
brought for seven years.
He'd been trying to
finish this song.
And brought it to us,
and it's like yeah,
we can, yeah, this is great.
And a lot of
creativity is about,
you know, making choices.
And that's what we
sort of specialize in.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So
seven years of creativity
crammed into three hours of
actually getting it done.
Let's take a look at the clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I had talked to Rob
with Acoustic Cafe
about doing this project.
And said, you know,
and he said, well,
if we only get three
hours, is that enough?
And I was like, yeah,
absolutely, that's enough.
And yet, there was a part
of me that was terrified.
The song got finished
very quickly.
Like within less than an
hour, we had the song down.
The first time I heard Sean
play the song through it
was, I mean it's
really a charge.
[MUSIC - SEAN ROWE, "THE COAT"]
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So that was
one of the pieces from the 2013
trip to South by Southwest.
Again, it came from nowhere
except seven years' worth
of ideas, and then three
hours later, it was that song.
One of the other artists
that we worked with in 2013
was an artist by the
name of Steve Poltz.
Steve Poltz is
one of those names
that you don't
know that you know.
But he is actually
the writer, one
of the co-writers behind
Jewel's smash breakout hit,
"You Were Meant For me."
So we got to write
with Steve Poltz
and then stayed
in touch with him,
and that led us to another
interesting opportunity, that
being Folk Alliance
and our first foray
into actual
broadcast television.
BEN ARTHUR: But
let's pause a moment
and say that the song that we
wrote with Steve was called,
"Your Mama has a Tramp Stamp."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
At South by, they
wrote, "the Tramp Stamp" song.
Very fun, bouncy.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, which he--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
don't have that on--
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah.
That's right.
Which he then,
that night, played
live in front of 300 people
at a club, and crowd-surfed.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Made them sing it.
Right.
It was--
BEN ARTHUR: Amazing
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So we
stayed in touch with him.
And there's a festival
called Folk Alliance that
happens in Kansas
City every year,
and through-- I don't know.
Explain to me the
conversation that took place
that, how we connected
with the next step.
BEN ARTHUR: So I was speaking
with a couple folks at PBS
because we've been
connected to some folks
at the national level.
And one of the folks
there suggested
we speak to the
local PBS station.
And because we had been talking
about expanding into what
we thought could be
a half-hour show,
I suggested that we maybe try
to collaborate on something.
And she said, Yeah, sure.
We'll give you a
crew, and we'll take
care of the capturing of it.
And, you know, because that's
expensive to get folks who are,
fly in folks from New York.
And we found a bar.
And Al and I went out
there and put together.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Cool.
And that turned into
a half-hour episode
which aired on KCPT,
which is the Kansas
City affiliate for PBS.
We have a clip of that too
that we'd like to show you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I do like time limits.
Because if you have to
write, and you give yourself
a deadline, it's
not always good.
There's no rules.
I gotta go.
My ride's here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Something the world
not being fair--
-Or--
-The first time I
touched your hair.
You know what I mean?
It's a little child.
Like, just wishing
the best for them.
-Yeah, it's nice.
-You know what I mean?
-I do.
I got a little
girl, so that just.
That worked for me.
-Oh good, that worked.
Let's go with that.
Tomorrow's-- No, we've
got to have that in there.
He was crying.
-I'm not crying.
You're crying.
-I'm Barbara Walters.
I'm getting it out of him.
-You're crying.
[MUSIC - STEVE POLTZ, "A LAST
PRAYER"]
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So right
after Folk Alliance then, again
it's South by Southwest.
And having taken on a
half-hour version of our show,
and completed the
year before what
we thought were pretty
successful forays into it,
we had a good bit of momentum,
feeling pretty confident,
had a bit more brand weight,
and so, going back down to South
by Southwest in 2014, we
struck out a little bit bigger.
Why don't you guys talk
about the 2014 South by?
ROB REINHART: Well,
from my perspective,
you went back to Fall
of 2013, I actually
ran into a couple of guys
who booked the festival.
And somehow they had heard
about this rogue effort
that we had put
together in 2013.
I don't know how.
And they said, would you be
interested in becoming actually
part of the festival in 2015?
We're like, yeah,
sure, that'd be great.
So they set us up with a panel.
So we knew that at
the end of the week,
we would be able to
actually present-- much
like we're doing here--
we'd be able to present
the work that we did as an
actual part of the festival.
Plus we got the badge.
And that was kind of nice too.
And then, we turned this
into-- then suddenly,
that homespun effort of 2013,
where we cobbled together
just enough to
meet our expenses,
suddenly we were confronted with
a budget and branded content.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, so through
a friend of a friend,
we ran into someone from Subway.
And they asked us if
they'd be, if we'd
be interested in working
with them as sponsors.
And it was like, and
you will give us money?
OK then, yes.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
I think at the time
they were doing a
big thing with South
by that was all about
Fresh, Get Fresh, Get Fresh.
And so one of the
angles we played was,
it doesn't come much
fresher than a song that
was written three hours ago.
That's pretty fresh.
It's OK.
We do-- we also had
the opportunity--
we did seven of the
songwriting sessions
over the course of five days.
And we hit probably the highest
mark on-- aside from Ben,
of course-- on the
talent scale, which
was Mercury Prize
nominees Turin Brakes, who
came in and joined us.
We do have a clip
of that as well.
And also a really great show.
So if we can roll that clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When it's just the
two of you for so long,
it can be quite isolating and,
you know, quite bare in a way.
And the minute someone else
starts throwing things in,
you have, you respond with
better ideas, as well.
It's not like-- it's
not like you're just
sitting there letting other--
the whole thing grows,
you know.
And we've, you talk
about maturity, but I do,
you know, we have finally
grown up as a band.
Like, it's taken us a long
time to get to the point
where we can relax and
go, this really works.
You know, let's have fun.
Let's, let's, let's invent
the future together, you know.
[MUSIC - TURIN BRAKES,
"INTERNATIONAL"]
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: A
couple things for me
with that one in particular
that I really enjoy.
And and with all of the
ones from that South by is,
that was our first foray
into real branded content,
paid ad placement, but we
were able to do in such a way
to where the ads are
baked into the video.
So you just saw a commercial
for Subway, Chaotica,
Taylor guitars, and a handful
of other sponsors, as well.
But we were able to present
it in a different way
than just commercials.
And that's always been something
that's been important to me
from the director side.
It's like, we don't want
to fall across that line
and be like "Ace of Cakes,"
which is a joke we made often.
And then, the other
bit was I'm pretty
sure that the word "liminal" was
placed in that song on a bet,
right?
BEN ARTHUR: I think so.
Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So seven
songwriting sessions at 2014
South by, plus the
half-hour episode.
That was basically my 2014.
I was in the edit bay
constantly getting that going.
What else was going on on
the brand front through 2014?
ROB REINHART: Well,
an interesting thing
coming out of South by
Southwest experience,
that budget from Subway
allowed all of us
to attend-- we had a full team.
We had seven artists, as you
mentioned, a larger place,
we so there was growth.
So there were
MICHAEL CREHORE: Nicer digs.
ROB REINHART: Nicer digs.
So that was good.
BEN ARTHUR: Better booze.
ROB REINHART: Right.
So coming out of
the festival, we
ran across a publicity person, a
PR person in Detroit, who said,
gee, you know, this
is a great project.
Maybe I should take
this to friends
at Ford, or Team Detroit,
actually-- their agency.
And we really got a
one word response.
Because this is what we pitched.
We pitched, you
would be involved
in this like Subway was.
BEN ARTHUR: But we were
like, wait a minute.
Will you pay us?
ROB REINHART: OK.
BEN ARTHUR: OK.
ROB REINHART: But their
response was no but
it was no but how do you feel
about putting this on the road?
And we came back to them with
a proposal, which really became
this Songs of the Road
Adventure through 2015,
and they sat there for
a couple of months.
And then they came back and
said, let's give it a try.
So it was taking the
songwriting sessions now,
and suddenly, we had to
move this and make it--
we had to literally move it and
make it a much larger project
and a larger team.
And it was amazing.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and the property,
the property itself is an
interesting mix at that point.
Because it is branded content.
We are baking in these sort
of commercial elements.
And then, it's a hybrid of like
reality TV, and documentary,
and then packaged
to be viewed online.
So you look like you
had something to--
ROB REINHART: Oh,
you know, but I
wanted to say
something just to be,
as long as we're talking
about branded content,
just to be very clear
because we're only
showing these little clips.
One of the things,
especially with Ford,
they specifically
did not want to be
involved in the creative
element of this project.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah.
It's important to
have that bright line.
ROB REINHART: Yeah.
They wanted to make
sure that-- they said,
we do not-- we were working
out of a Ford C-MAX Energy,
and they said, we don't
want songs about Ford.
We don't want songs
about C-MAX and hybrids.
BEN ARTHUR: They did
have one request.
They didn't want any
songs about car accidents.
They were--
ROB REINHART: --or what might
happen in the back of a car.
They just let's shy away, maybe.
But really, all they
were interested in
is that the creative process
would, at some point,
involve being in the automobile.
Well, if we were on a road trip,
we had to be in the automobile.
So that was really great.
I mean, I was pleasantly
surprised by that.
I thought that they would
want a firmer hand in that.
They wanted nothing.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
and this whole thing
raised a new
interesting challenge
for you, Al and Mike, in that
a lot of the show-- not a lot
of the show-- a fair amount of
the show takes place in a car.
MICHAEL CREHORE: Right.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
then, the rest of the show
takes place that a car
can take you from or to,
and rarely is that
a recording studio.
So how did that change
your whole approach
to your involvement
in the project?
ALAN HOUGHTON: Well, one, you
know, mundane, but big aspect,
was in a car, where
a lot of the dialogue
between the songwriters
is taking place--
as they're trying to brainstorm
the lyrics and stuff-- you
have to record that.
And get it clean.
And it's hard in a moving car.
A little car sounds funny.
And it's hard to monitor
because there's only room
for so many people in the car.
So you don't know what
you're recording, really.
So that was a whole learning
curve doing that thing.
And then, of course,
you don't always
know where you're going
to end up to record,
depending on if you're in
Nashville, or LA, or Detroit,
or whatever.
So the other aspect is
the actual music recording
of production with
whatever artist
is, you know, online for
that thing the whole day.
So that's another aspect of it.
MICHAEL CREHORE: Yeah
we've been, and I think.
It was interesting because
we got to the kind of decide
depending on where
we were going to go.
We were in Memphis
for one recording.
We were in Austin for
another recording.
We were in LA.
We were in Woodstock, New
York, and we were in Detroit.
So in Memphis, which
was the first recording,
we got to work at
Sun Studios, which
was this iconic studio,
which is now run as more of a
BEN ARTHUR: Museum.
MICHAEL CREHORE: Museum.
But you can still rent it out
at night to do recordings.
But when you record
there, you record
the way they used to record.
So it's an 8-track.
BEN ARTHUR: No headphones.
MICHAEL CREHORE: No headphones.
All in the same room.
All analog.
So your, that's a
certain kind of sound.
When we went to Boston,
we piggybacked on South
by Southwest 2015 and did
a few artists in a condo.
But then the artists that
we worked with on Songs
on the Road, we did that
all kind of in a, you know,
gorilla style.
Ad hoc.
But then in LA, we got
to go into the Village
Recorders, which was an
amazing iconic studio.
In Woodstock, we got
to work in a great
BEN ARTHUR: Each
new place, you know,
sort of brought a new thing.
ALAN HOUGHTON: I mean, one of
the elements-- given the fact
that we're on the road now,
we're moving from one place
to another, and
cameras all around,
and it's, how it's a little
more disconcerting for artists,
especially the new, the featured
artists, who's never done this.
So when we finally
did get to the studio,
and we had to get a performance,
there was a lot more, hey,
you know, this is--
trying to create
an environment that's nurturing
and makes that able to happen.
You know, even in
South by Southwest,
where we had a-- we could
set up in our condo.
And we had that set up.
And people would come in.
But it was a pretty
controlled environment,
even though we just set
it up for that week.
But in these situations, OK,
we're, here we are the studio.
And at 3 o'clock, we're leaving.
So we have to look around
and see what's going on,
and what kind of talent we have,
and what the studio is like,
and try to get the
best performance out
of a very harried artist.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah,
at heart, there's
a contradiction in the
show, which is to say,
the excitement and the fear
is part of what is compelling
and fun.
You know, the tick, tick, tick
element adds to the stakes.
But when it comes to actually
getting the song down--
and writing it, for that
matter-- if the artist is
freaking out, then you're
going to have a crappy song.
MICHAEL CREHORE: And you're
ready for that moment,
and all of a sudden
it's, hold on a second.
Gotta get that
other camera angle.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah.
Al tends to take
on the role often
of like the yogi in the
room keeping everybody calm,
keeping the vibe.
I just expect him,
one of these days,
to walk in with like
sticks of incense.
Don't worry.
it's all going to be OK.
BEN ARTHUR: Take one of these.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
I think we have
a clip from the first
episode of our partnership.
This features a Nashville
artist, Lera Lynn,
who has recently seen some
success on True Detective.
BEN ARTHUR: True
Detective, yeah.
She starred in it.
And they used a song that
she co-wrote with Roseanne
Cash and T-Bone Burnett.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And
next time, a song that she
co-wrote with us.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, totally.
We're working on that.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So if we
can show the Lera Lynn clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm Lera Lynn.
I am a singing songwriter
from Nashville, Tennessee.
I have no anxiety
about writing the song,
or recording the song.
I'm really excited.
I mean, that's what
this is all about,
you know, to get to create
music and record it.
That's the best
part of this job.
-So I guess I was
wondering about home,
you know, just as a sort
of starting off place.
-So I pictured,
maybe, this couple
lying together and
pretending that everything
is going to be OK.
Even though they're maybe,
-Maybe it, maybe it's a breakup.
It could potentially
be like a story
about knowing that it was over.
-Someone's been travelling.
And they're coming
home to someone
that they don't feel like
they're coming home to anymore.
Right.
I love it.
-OK.
-I love it.
Write it.
-OK.
-I'm going to get some coffee.
Just kidding.
[MUSIC - LERA LYNN, "NOT HOME
ANYMORE"]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL CREHORE: Oh yeah,
we forgot about that
until the last minute.
Undeliverable.
ROB REINHART: Al and Mike
talked about the fact
that we did stop by
studios-- some really
beautiful and iconic studios
over the course of this year--
but each one of
these episodes also
had to result in a
live performance done
using the car as the PA for the
performance, which is, what you
just saw there was a
performance we did in a very
odd space in Memphis, where
we set up, and actually
had a live audience.
Each one of these
had live audiences.
So there are about
33, 40 people that you
didn't see in that
shot listening
to that performance that was
then channeled through the car
and recorded that way, right?
Additional.
BEN ARTHUR: Right.
ALAN HOUGHTON: It
was a long day.
BEN ARTHUR: It was
a long day, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So we've--
this show continued to evolve.
And we continued to get better
at it, I think, as we went on.
Putting them
together, because now
we're doing this whole thing.
It's not just like an Ace
of Cakes reality show.
There's this
performance element.
So now we're
striking out, saying,
hey we can do better than
American Idol at having
live performances.
We can do better than Ace of
Cakes than being, you know,
entertaining, and
telling honest reality,
instead of whatever that is.
I don't even know what that is.
BEN ARTHUR: The nice
thing is, you know,
you can't eat the
cake when you watch
one of these baking shows.
But you actually
get to take the song
and live with it separately
from the show, which
I imagine is also delicious.
I hope.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So that
pretty much brings us up
to the present.
We published four episodes of
Songs to the Road this year.
We have one more coming.
And it puts us into
facing the next year.
BEN ARTHUR: Well, there's
also the KCPT new.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Oh, yeah.
Flashback.
So remember the Steve Poltz
piece, the half-hour episode.
BEN ARTHUR: Right.
So KCPT PBS station
aired the show
and called me a couple
weeks afterwards and said,
hey, we'd like to put you
in for an Emmy nomination.
And so I called everybody.
I was like, that's OK, right?
And to our delight, a
couple months later,
we got a notification that we'd
been nominated for an Emmy.
I went to the Emmys--
the mid-America Emmys
is what these are called-- and
sadly, we lost to a documentary
about the Rams'
cheerleaders photo shoot.
No, it was the Rams.
It was the Rams.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Was it?
BEN ARTHUR: It was the Rams.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Aww,
it wasn't even a good team?
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah.
But there are certain
things that we can't compete
with, you know what I'm saying?
And
ROB REINHART: Do our best.
BEN ARTHUR: It's fair.
It's fair.
So anyway, but it actually
was an honor-- totally
unexpected-- to be nominated
for our first half-hour show.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So facing that.
Emmy nominations, brands
bigger than it's been,
viewcounts are higher
than they've been.
We've continued our, you
know, thankfully, touch wood,
continued our path of growth.
Where does that put us now,
facing into the next year?
BEN ARTHUR: Well, we
have one more episode
of The Songs of the Road to
launch in the next couple
weeks.
And then, hopefully
we can figure out
a way to continue to grow.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: What do you
think-- we do want to show you
guys one more clip.
And it is a sneak peak of the
episode that has not yet aired.
So we're going to do that.
And afterwards, we
want to take Q&A.
If anybody has any
questions, there
are Q&A mikes in
the aisles, please.
We'd love to chat with
you guys about this stuff.
If there's one thing that you
could sum up and take away
from the past what is
now six years of working
on this project for some
of us, like what do you--
what do you think?
Stumped him with that.
BEN ARTHUR: It's an
exciting project.
It's fun.
And I, you know, as
long as the process
itself continues to be
as exciting, and weird,
and frightening, as
this is, and as long
as we continue--
I mean, it really,
it comes down to the art, right?
So if we do it, if we make a
cake-- to go back to the cake
metaphor-- that people
take home and, you know,
listen to cake listeningwise,
and it's rotten,
then we failed.
At heart, it's a fun challenge.
But if the art itself
isn't the center,
doesn't hold that center,
then it doesn't work.
And it doesn't work, I
think, internally for us too.
The art has to have a life,
and to lift up, and feel
like, yeah, that's a good song.
Beyond just the
time limit, I think
as long as that
continues to hold true,
we're going to keep doing it.
ALAN HOUGHTON: Yeah, it's
an interesting-- it was not
a quandary, but it was an issue
to confront early on, given
all the reality TV
that's out there,
is you do have this tense
situation that can, you know,
it can go south.
With throwing in the
wrong flavors when--
BEN ARTHUR: --of the cake.
ALAN HOUGHTON: Of the cake, yes.
ROB REINHART: The song cake.
BEN ARTHUR: I never should
have mentioned cake.
ALAN HOUGHTON: Yeah, the
artists can not get it together,
some of them can have a fit.
You can, it doesn't take
much to blow that vibe.
And a TV producer
could even argue,
you know, yeah, let's
screw it up a little bit
and have some drama, and who
cares if the song-- you know,
if the artist storms out
the door, that's great.
That's what we're looking for.
That's perfect.
But we, you know, we made a
conscious decision, that's
not what we're going to do.
We are actually going to end
up with a really good song
at the end.
And one of the
things that's really
heartening about the show--
and it's a surprise to me,
and probably everybody
a little bit--
is given all the
random elements,
and everything that
goes into this,
is how resourceful people are.
We're not a big team, you know.
And we pull off
a show like this.
But also the artists
who are featured
bring everything to bear in
a super short amount of time
and create what've been
really great songs.
It's probably startling.
MICHAEL CREHORE: Rob
and I were talking
about that the other day.
Because we-- for this
talk we kind of went back
through the archives and
Matthew had mentioned,
do we have all the
music in one place?
And I said, oh yeah, we
should, we should do that.
So I put all the
music in one place.
And, you know, we've
got about 20 songs now
that we've written over
the past few years.
And they all hold up as--
individually and collectively--
as really nice songs
and it's enjoyable.
ROB REINHART:
Acoustic Cafe-- this
is what that program is about.
It's about song craft.
Not this song craft,
but it's about the craft
of making songs.
So I listen to a lot of songs.
So 21 years down
the road, what I
can say about this project
which has been so gratifying
is that there is no template.
Every one of these
situations is different.
I kept thinking that
we'd get into a pattern.
And the pattern, we would then
go and execute the pattern.
What's great, what's
refreshing, what's fun
is that there is no pattern.
Every one of these,
I think everyone's
about to become a
spectacular failure.
BEN ARTHUR: It is.
It absolutely is.
ROB REINHART: And
then it's awesome.
And it's great.
One of, one of
these days it may.
BEN ARTHUR: I thought, I
would have put money down
that we would have crashed
into a wall before this.
I absolutely would have.
ROB REINHART: And this
new one, you know what?
I am, so every one,
I'm just thrilled
to get to the next
one, to be able to do
the segment for
the radio program,
put it out there on the 100
affiliates that we have,
and get it heard in the world.
This new one, I can't wait.
December 7.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yup.
December 7 the last episode of
this year's Songs of the Road
will to air.
It publishes on YouTube.
We use the YouTube network
to publish these things,
and to share them out, and
to make them available.
And I can say,
from my standpoint
as the director and
editor of these things
to put it together, it's always
been very important to me
to be honest in
our storytelling,
and to show you what is more
a documentary of the story
unfolding, rather than
to try to manhandle,
and manipulate, and go
that route of reality TV.
I think a lot of
those shows, they
focus-- even on, not even one
when it's the task at hand.
You know, they want the
bickering, and the argument
on the side, and
whatever the show's about
is actually only
a couple minutes.
And instead, we've tried to
put forward an honest telling
of hey, this is what went down.
And I think it shows
a glimpse into a world
that a lot of people
don't get to see.
Unless you're in that
room, unless you're
one of the people writing
that song, in a normal world
you would never get access.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, and that's
a funny thing about artists
is that I think a
lot of us really
love that creative thing that
is largely a private affair,
you know?
Like, except for opportunities
like this, for the most part
it's done away.
But it's one of the things
that I get a huge kick out of,
and I think a lot of artists
get a huge kick out of.
And sort of opening
up the window on that,
and sharing that
true fear and joy
is one of the great
pleasures of the show.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and there's
a lot of stuff to be learned,
I think, about it too.
No artists have
worked the same way.
Some want to do lyrics first.
Some want to do music first.
And then, we haven't ever
really recorded it the same way.
So even if you're into
that stuff, you can--
ROB REINHART: Yeah,
every single one
has been completely different.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So we
will give you a sneak peak
of this last little clip.
This features a very
talented artist.
My Brightest Diamond, Shara
Worden, who is from Detroit.
And we went to Detroit to do it.
And it was quite an event.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, and
a brand new style.
She wanted to write something
and have a DJ manipulate
the pieces and
then sort of start
from that thing which
she hadn't yet heard,
which we had never tried before,
and we'd never worked with a DJ
before.
And she also wanted a
horn section, so it was.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Upping the ante.
Here's a little tease
of the upcoming episode.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Raise your hand if you're
ready to go perform it live.
The show, The Eastern
Market is leaving.
All right.
Who's driving it?
-Have fun.
Listen, I'll go.
-OK.
I personally feel like
the live performance
is going to be great.
-Wiz is going to do this
all live and take that risk
because that brings her to
a new level of performance.
-The most important thing
for me in a live experience
is feeling, feeling,
feeling, feeling, feeling.
It's a really hard part to sing.
And I've never sang without
a guitar in front of me.
I may actually just
hold it in front of me
like a security blanket.
And I've never sang
anything this high.
We've never had an
audience this big.
And it's Rob's hometown.
And it's yeah, some pressure.
-The performance is going
to be the very first time
that all six of us
are playing this song.
Together, first time,
in front of people.
We are definitely
working without a net.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So
I encourage you guys.
December 7 that'll be available
on our YouTube channel, Song
Craft Presents.
And guys, anything you want
to say before we open up
for questions?
ROB REINHART: Thank
you for taking time.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Happily,
if anyone has any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
I'm Lauren.
Thank you for coming.
I love your project.
I had a quick question.
I wondered how'd you guys find
your talent and the artist
in each of the cities?
ROB REINHART: Well, we
sort of crafted lists.
I mean, I'm sort of,
for the radio program,
I'm in touch with a
lot of just people.
And when we knew we were going
to be in a particular place,
they weren't necessarily
artists from that city.
In a couple of cases,
we had that happen.
And then, in others,
you know, people
were just going to be
at South by Southwest.
And if they were going to be
there, we would bring them,
you know, we would
extend the invitation.
A lot of artists--
you know, the key
was finding an artist where this
project would work for them.
We had a lot of
artists who said,
boy, that sounds
like a lot of fun,
but I would be
terrified to do that.
I can't do it.
So a lot of people
just turned us down.
BEN ARTHUR: Aesop Rock-- Aesop
Rock is a friend of Wiz's-- DJ
Wiz-- and I asked
him to ask Ace.
And Ace emailed
back and was like,
I would never stop throwing up.
So it's out of the question.
MICHAEL CREHORE: And
one of our artists,
David Mayfield, who
was he was Nashville
based for a long time, he's
now back in his native Ohio.
We actually recorded
him in Los Angeles.
So we had-- it was a different
kind of a road experience--
but the interesting thing was
we rented an Airbnb which turned
out to be Roger Miller's house.
And Roger Miller
wrote King of the Road
and a bunch of other great hits.
And Roger Miller, as I'm driving
around with David Mayfield,
I said, you know, we're
staying at Roger Miller's house
tonight?
And he just, he
completely broke down.
Roger Miller was
his boyhood hero,
as a singer,
songwriter, entertainer.
And so it was just this
weird confluence of events
that we were staying in
Roger Miller's house,
we're going to be working
in Roger Miller's house
ROB REINHART: With
an artist from Ohio.
MICHAEL CREHORE: With
an artist from Ohio,
who that was his hero.
So it's kind of an
interesting thing.
BEN ARTHUR: To get, to
drill in a little more.
Rob's show-- he doesn't
mention this often.
But Rob's show airs for
something like 2 and 1/2
million people a week.
So he gets pitched
every artist who
has music within the range
of stuff Acoustic Cafe plays.
So he's, you know, very
in touch with what's
out there in the world.
And so that, plus all of
our collective fandoms
of various people,
and I think all of us
have at various points pitched
people that we were just like,
oh, man, I love her.
She's amazing.
We need to get her on the show.
And sometimes it
works scheduling-wise,
and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes it works as far as
the fear-- vomiting-- factor.
And sometimes it doesn't.
But every once in
awhile, we get,
you know, the
people that we want.
And it's a real thrill.
ROB REINHART: And we also
wanted to allow the artist
to help to, you know,
design the trip.
So, what would inspire you
to create something great?
So with Lera Lynn, she's
like, well-- you know,
you know, within a three hour
road trip, that kind of thing--
she said, well, why
don't we go to Memphis?
And then, the whole thought
of going to Sun Studios
was a real thrill for her.
Yeah, I mean, so, you
know, we wanted people
to-- Shara Worden,
obviously she wanted
to do kind of a love letter
to Detroit in Detroit.
We opened it up to her.
We said, we can go
anywhere you want to go.
And she said, I want
to stay in Detroit.
I want to do it there.
So that was another
part that went
into the selection,
where they wanted,
what would inspire
them the most.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Thanks for your question.
BEN ARTHUR: Thanks.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Any
additional questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yeah, I've got lots of
questions, but I guess
BEN ARTHUR: Hit us
with all of them.
We'll take them all.
AUDIENCE: The one that
I'm kind of curious
about it is just about
those choking points,
when people like
just realize I don't
think we can do this in
time, or anything like that.
Have you actually had to extend
the clock for people in order
to get something done?
BEN ARTHUR: Not really.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's funny.
We've actually had to turn
the screws on bringing
certain things to a close.
With the sneak peek
episode-- the new one that
will come out-- there
was a point where
I was kind of running around
the studios we're recording
in saying, guys, it's time.
We gotta go.
And they still wanted
to do more vocal takes.
You saw them sitting
in the booth.
BEN ARTHUR: I was trying.
So, you know, what
usually happens
is we talk to an artist,
and they're like, well,
how long would I need to,
you know, maybe the manager,
how long would the artist
need to be available?
We can only give you
three hours, or whatever.
We say now that we've learned,
we'll ask of you three hours.
But give us an extra
two hours on the end
because your artist will want
to spend more time doing this.
Your artist will not be happy
with, you know, the bridge,
or with the vocal.
And they will want
to keep playing.
Because really it's
genuinely a joy.
AUDIENCE: Is it mostly-- is
the time extension mostly then
for sort of
production type stuff?
Like at that point, you've
got lyrics, and melody,
and all that stuff down?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah,
I think that's fair.
MICHAEL CREHORE: I
don't think we've ever
come up to the end of the
clock and not had the song.
The song seems to come together,
and I think most of that
has to do with Ben.
Bend is a really
great facilitator
in the songwriting process.
BEN ARTHUR: Thanks.
MICHAEL CREHORE: And it's true.
He'll, he'll, you know,
whatever they're going through,
you know, it'll get to a point.
And he'll bring it to a close.
Sometimes he's used
the process of,
let's go into separate rooms.
You bring a verse.
I'll bring a verse.
And sometimes they just
hit it off right away.
BEN ARTHUR: It's
actually something
that-- Matthew's encouraged
me to slow down a little bit.
Because the fear gets into me
too, even after all this time.
And I'll push into
territory that, you know,
maybe if I gave a little
more space the artist,
they'd-- you know, because
you see the sort of blank
expression.
And so I will, out of
empathy, if nothing else,
try to rush in.
And Matthew has been
very good about reminding
me to, you know, like
a good psychoanalyst,
let it hang a little bit.
And see if that space, they'll
come in and fill that space.
So the creatively, almost
never that I recall,
Ben Sollee and Erin McKeown took
a little bit longer than some.
But usually it's a production.
The artist wants
to keep polishing.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
I could see where
that would be--
MICHAEL CREHORE: The thing
that important for Al and I
is, I think, is to get a
performance of the vocal.
Because at the end of
the day, we may not--
you know, if we get
that lead performance,
one that we know
we can work with.
We're not big proponents of
tuning, and moving things
around, and making
everything perfect.
We're a little more old school.
So we want to make sure that
performance is something
that we can then
build a track around.
And in some cases, we
worked with A.J. Croce
down in the South by Southwest.
And we really couldn't
do anything to his track.
BEN ARTHUR: He asked us to.
MICHAEL CREHORE: It was
such a beautiful, yeah,
it was such a beautiful
performance of the vocal,
and the guitar--
acoustic guitar--
that we didn't
want to produce it.
We started to produce it,
and we went, you know what?
This is
AUDIENCE: That was the one
we saw initially there?
BEN ARTHUR: No.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: No
you'll have to go online
MICHAEL CREHORE: --to
go online to see it.
But it's just a really, you
know, that was all it needed.
And for some of the
others, we produced them.
Brought them up a little bit
with either drums, or bass,
or some extra guitars,
or some keyboards,
but it's just really getting
that vocal, you know?
ALAN HOUGHTON: Yeah,
and to your point,
these songwriters
are professional.
You know?
If you say, you know, 3
o'clock, we have to go.
Because we have
to be at the place
where you're actually going
to sing the song in front
of 40 people, you know,
they don't ignore that.
You know.
So everyone's working
to make it happen.
And maybe, yeah, it'd great
to have 15 extra minutes,
but sometimes you don't.
You know?
And you just go
with what you got.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Also
from a technical standpoint,
and I think this applies
a bit to Mike and Al
as well, but
definitely from where
I'm coming from
from the video side,
is that we're essentially
there to document.
So we definitely don't
want to be pushing it
in any certain way to
try and-- because then we
fall into that, just like
any other reality TV show,
and we're not telling you
the honest story anymore.
So one of the mottos
on the set all the time
is, default to reality.
What's really going on?
What can we really do?
And any times when we've
come to the wire, where we've
had to be like, we don't
have any more time,
it's because the live
performance is scheduled.
And people, the audience
is starting to show up.
And they're like, well,
are they going to show up?
Are they going to perform?
So a lot of that is reality
setting that timeline versus us
trying to manipulate the story.
And I think that's true a little
bit with the songs as well.
You guys are just documenting
those beautiful moments,
and then, you know,
touching it where you can.
MICHAEL CREHORE: Yeah,
we're not-- we're not--
very light-handed production.
BEN ARTHUR: And as per
the artist's instruction.
Essentially, at the end of
a recording session, we say,
is there anything you
want us to augment or add?
And then, depending
on what they want,
we'll do that, send it to
them, and say, this is right?
And sometimes it is,
sometimes it isn't.
And then, and then, move on.
Because at the end
of the day, we're
serving that artist's vision.
And if the song doesn't
sound like the artist
and doesn't sound natural,
like that's not going
to be good for us or them.
AUDIENCE: Well, thanks, you
answered a lot of questions.
ROB REINHART: Thank
you very much.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Unfortunately, we're
out of time, or we'd
take a couple more.
If you guys do want to see the
full episodes of the shows,
and everything
we've done out, you
can go to songcraftpresents.com,
or go straight to the source,
and go to YouTube.com
slash songcraftpresents.
Thank you guys for taking
the time to join me.
Thank you as an audience.
ROB REINHART: Thank you.
MICHAEL CREHORE:
Thanks, Matthew.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Thank you very much.
BEN ARTHUR: Thank you, Matthew.
[APPLAUSE]